hello my name is reto meier and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday August fifth 2013 last week I
wave my hands around an a sign of
unbridled excitement as I introduced
Android 4.3 in exciting gourmet flavor
of jelly bean available for your
development pleasure Stefan took a
deeper dive into one of these new
Android 4.3 features with a look at the
new UI automation testing tool kit while
anchor continued his series on making
apps beautiful with a glance back at
backwards compatibility and a fresh new
take on modernization not to be outdone
check did some stretching and squashing
and also recorded a dev bite on
animation the July Android developer
survey closed last week with 6,000
Android developers sharing their
thoughts it was no surprise to see the
US developers account for the largest
number of responses but which country do
you think filled the number two spot the
Google Play game services team have
found an ingenious way to ensure that
they have more time for playing games by
having you do their jobs for them with
the launch of the public bug tracker for
Google Play game services join them this
week for another episode of game on
where they'll be taking you through the
process or savings game state to the
cloud our European colleagues join the
Paris android usergroup for what I'm
sure was a debaucherous event filled
with fine wine soft cheeses and some
Android development or at least that's
what their expense report suggests
coming up this week jf is back with a
breakdown of how to detect overdraw
using the hierarchy viewer and Nick the
butcher has prepared some fine cuts of
aged in marble design by it's starting
this week with a look at responsive
design not to be outdone keep an eye out
for the latest from Chet as he delves
into the magical world of cartoon
animation techniques also this week our
Australian advocates will be hosting the
second part of their making apps
beautiful backstage show join them to
ask questions on how you can make your
apps a little more magical that's all
for this week in Android development
before sure to check out this week's dev
and design bites and know that I'll set
fire to your new shoes